the Sun has risen on an independent
United Kingdom and just look at it even
the weather's improved it's been a hell
of a long journey this I first got
involved in Euroskeptic politics 25
years ago and the first election I
contested I managed to beat the late
great screaming Lord Sutch by 164 votes
so I didn't come last and now there are
17 million people that voted for brexit
it's a victory for ordinary people
decent people it's a victory against the
big merchant banks against the big
businesses and against big politics and
I'm proud of everybody that had the
courage in the face of all the threats
everything they were told they had the
guts to stand up and do the right thing
the election was won in my view in the
Midlands of a north and I think it was
the old Labour vote that came to us and
we particularly as a party campaigned as
hard as we could in those areas there is
still a massive disconnect between
Westminster sw1 and real communities and
the the one image I will remember
throughout throughout the rest of my
life was a woman in Bolton grabbing my
hands with tears in her eyes saying why
doesn't David Cameron why doesn't the
government come and see what they've
done to my community what they've done
to the prospects for my kids
people here don't understand they're too
wealthy they don't get what open door
mass immigration as a result of EU
membership has done to people's wages to
be was a availability of getting GP
appointments or their kids into local
schools this was the issue ultimately
that won this election so I'm thrilled
that we've done this I believe the other
big effect of this election
it's not what's happened in Britain but
what would happen in the rest of Europe
I mean the rest of the EU euro skeptic
parties never talked about leaving the
EU now they are an opinion poll Irma
neverland's said that a majority there
now want to lead leave so we may well be
close perhaps to NEX it and similarly in
Denmark a majority there are in favour
of leaving so we could be quite close to
decks it and I'm told the same may apply
to Sweden and perhaps Austria and
perhaps even Italy too
the EU is failing the EU is dying I hope
we've knocked the first brick out of the
wall I hope this is the first step
towards a Europe of sovereign
nation-states trading together neighbors
together friends together but without
flags anthems or useless old unelected
presidents so what happens now what
happens next well 70 million people have
said we must leave the European Union we
now need a brexit government a
government that gets on with a job a
government that begins the renegotiation
of our trade relationship a government
that'll be mindful that already many of
the German car manufacturing unions have
said let's get on and do a deal let's go
on buying selling motorcars and wine and
cheese with each other but a government
also that at the same time uses the
opportunity of brexit and the
opportunity is we're now freed to start
making our own trade deals and
associations with the rest of the world
we've left behind with this result we've
left behind a failing political union
we've given ourselves the chance to
rejoin the world in a 21st century
global economy so we need as I say a
brexit government we need the
negotiations to start as soon as humanly
possible we need to start thinking
globally about our future and the other
thing I think that needs to happen is
that June the 23rd needs to become a
national bank holiday and we will call
it Independence Day